the illegal aliens that we're seeing who
are
crossing our very unsecure border of the
atmosphere and the u.s government
officials who were talking about
the ufos that apparently are 100 to 1
000 years
more advanced than our our technology is
right now
i am i got to say i'm a little bit of an
alien
skeptic not so you know i assume it's
the chinese or someone has put it making
this technology
but if not you know i even i just
doesn't this doesn't interest me as much
you have a different opinion i do well
mainly it's
someone here everyone here seems to be
alien skeptic here at the daily wire
from what i can tell someone someone has
to to come out on the pro alien side so
i've decided to take that role
i admit that i'm fully on board with the
ufo thing
i'm going to say right now i think
they're space aliens i admit that 85
of my opinion is based on what i hope is
true so i i am putting feelings over
facts in this case i try not to do that
generally but here it's it's feelings
over facts for me
i just want it to be true um but the 15
of of uh that is not feeling i would say
look we we do know that there's
something flying around
in the skies we've got we've got video
we've got radar we've also got
eyewitness accounts from navy pilots you
know 60 minutes did a thing that
four navy pilots who observed this thing
flying around for five minutes so you
got
expert eyewitnesses who this is what
they do for a living they detect threats
in the sky
they observe this thing for five minutes
at a time
sustained up close that's confirmed by
radar
and by video which public can see um
that's pretty compelling
evidence at least that there was
something there so we know that's not a
camera trick we know it's not
hallucination
something was there now it's just a
question of what the heck was that thing
and um either it's from this earth or
it's not and if it's from this earth
then there's some
foreign entity that has technology
that's you know
centuries beyond our own and if that's
the case then you know if china has that
has
the ability to build things that can
basically break the laws of
laws of physics from what we understand
why haven't they already
conquered us and subjugated us by now i
mean if they have that kind of
technology
it just raises questions so there's
probably a million explanations that
don't invoke space aliens but i'm
leaping right to the space aliens
i'm pleased that you would leap that way
i do have an answer on the china
question of it all which is
the reason they haven't just totally
conquered us yet is we just keep giving
them all our money and all our our
ip and all our you know our culture
and stuff so what do you think what do
you think it is what do you think the
the tic tac uh thing that's flying
around over the ocean
no it stops on a dime then goes 80 000
miles an hour and
what is that no you're i mean it is it
is entirely possible
i can't believe i have to it is entirely
possible that it's a little green man
i'm not even being positioned
it is possible you haven't persuaded me
that that's likely
but i'm willing to keep an open mind you
know you and i we're very open-minded
people
our political opponents don't understand
that cabot
what the hell is this all right so i
have a timeline for you here i'm going
to walk you through
because i think there are like two parts
of this conversation there's the one
part that's goofy where we all laugh at
it we say
this is hilarious it's ufos it's aliens
whatever yeah and then there's the other
part where you say okay
there are enough serious officials
within the united states government that
are saying
this is a national security threat there
are things that have been documented we
don't know what they are
let's figure it out so i think it it is
important to have like a serious
conversation while at the same time
couching in a fun way
it's going to give you a quick timeline
okay so early 2000s a lot of our pilots
start seeing a lot more
ufo sightings they call them uaps in the
government
they start making reports in 2007 harry
reid
who at the time was the senate majority
leader comes out and says we're going to
create a government program to
investigate all of these
uaps that's called the advanced
aerospace threat identification program
this runs for five years it's a top
secret operation within the pentagon
they document all sorts of uaps there
from pilots saying there are things they
can't explain that are observing
off of the coast of ships off the coast
of our seas popping up
middle of nowhere they're investigating
they're gathering evidence getting many
of these things on videos
so for five years those videos are kept
secret and then at the end of the five
years
budget cuts come in and that government
program is shut down in 2012.
over the next few years there are still
even more sightings that are going on
with pilots
people saying we have no clue what these
things are so in 2019
the pentagon restarts another program
called the unidentified aerial phenomena
task force
that's created in 2019-2020 they start
getting together even more videos of
things things that are traveling they're
saying on radar
going up and down 80 000 feet in two to
three seconds things that are far beyond
u.s technology at this point
so then they start releasing some of
these videos to the public in 2019-2020
the government says these are authentic
as of last month they come out and they
say yeah all those videos that were
leaked some of the videos that you saw
those are all authentic videos we don't
know what they are
and so now the senate intelligence
committee has said wait a second this is
a national security threat the us
government truly doesn't know what they
are
i think a lot of people were saying well
maybe this is the us government the
intel committee is saying this isn't us
we need to investigate so there's going
to be a hearing next month
where this unidentified aerial phenomena
task force is going to have to present
their findings as of now
to these senate intelligence committees
so we're going to be getting a lot more
answers on what a lot of these things
are on video
what a lot of these uh reportings are so
it seems to me there are
multiple stages before we get to the
point that mars attacks
right there the first question is is it
us
i know that government officials are
saying that it's not us
and we know that the government would
never lie to the american people right
we haven't just been through that ringer
so
i think we gotta we gotta try to answer
that question first but then let's say
that
the government officials are above board
it actually isn't
us or any segment of the federal
government
isn't it just the chinese i don't know i
mean what i'm being told is that we
don't have the capabilities to make this
kind of technology
whoever made this is far more advanced
than we are in terms of math in terms of
physics
in terms of engineering it's just the
chinese right isn't that
isn't that a fair assumption yeah so to
get to both your questions there the
first one and i'm not some ideologue one
way or the other on this
i'm just kind of letting you know where
things are right now which is usually
what conspiracy theorists say they'd say
look i don't have a dog
i'm just fighting questions just asking
the questions okay so to answer your
ques first question
is it the united states government oh it
absolutely could be
and i think the timing is interesting
space force just comes out
wouldn't this be a great way to rally
support for space force funding and if
people start saying well do we really
need space force yeah it would be great
timing for them to say well look at all
this stuff this is why we need to pour
billions and billions of dollars in the
space force
that makes sense however the pentagon is
saying we're releasing all of this
footage now because in their words quote
the videos did not reveal any sensitive
information or capabilities
so the only videos we're seeing are ones
that they're saying these are the ones
that don't reveal any sensitive
capabilities i'm wondering what other
videos there are
and also people are saying and i agree
with this point if it is us
why release the videos we're kind of
tipping our hand if it is us
and there could be some lack of
communication where it's it's some other
government entity and the pentagon is
doing this against their will releasing
these videos if it is the chinese
there has been some sort of quantum leap
our defense officials in all of these
interviews that you're reading
they're coming out saying if it's a
chinese they are
far beyond anything we imagined but at
the same time why is that technology not
manifesting itself in other areas of
their military
their navy their their nuclear
submarines their aircraft carriers are
archaic compared to the united states
military yeah
and so why is it not manifesting it
there i want to read a couple quotes too
sean cahill the u.s navy chief master at
arms said
what they're seeing quote indicates a
technology that outstrips our arsenal by
at least 100 years to a thousand years
at the moment
chris mellon the deputy assistant
secretary of defense for intelligence
under presidents clinton and george w
bush said quote the acceleration is far
beyond anything we're capable of there's
nothing we can build that would be
strong enough to endure the amount of
force and acceleration that we're seeing
so these are like legit government
officials these aren't some random guy
that says oh i used to be in the navy
and we'd see these things all the time
these are real people saying uh guys we
need to look at this and if it is the
chinese
that's terrifying i actually think
that's more terrifying than this being
some otherworldly thing because if it's
the chinese that are doing this
they've got stuff that we can't even
compete with or at least we can't
compete with based on what our
government is saying that's true we
might be able to compete with the
martians but
i think we've proven over the last 20
years we cannot compete with the chinese
okay
so i i accept those answers
let's go to the craziest possible
conclusion let's go there michael let's
go
and let's say just like in that movie
from the 90s it's the guys with the
brain heads and the helmets and the beep
boop right and all that
and the the martians are here they they
haven't really been
uh attacking us or anything right
there's they're just kind of they've got
their little tic tacs
and they're making some trouble in the
oceans but nothing too aggressive
i can't believe i'm asking this on the
air what what does it mean for us
if there are aliens intelligent aliens
visiting earth i love that you start
laughing right as you say that i'm
laughing as i'm hearing it
i don't know what it means michael i'm
not some ufo guy i don't sit around
thinking about these things i know you
bring me on as the ufo expert you you
have to go i like behind you
i'm more fascinated in this story and i
can't believe more people aren't talking
about this frankly i mean
this was one of the number one stories
on the daily wire for the last couple
days
because of the fact that i do think
people are interested in it but from a
national media standpoint it
kind of seems like it made a little blip
on the radar 60 minutes ran the piece
but now i think everyone is afraid of
being viewed as crazy
everyone is afraid of acknowledging that
elephant in the room so okay
our government is saying that it's not
us and it's a hundred to a thousand
years ahead of us
our government is also telling us don't
worry we're way ahead of the chinese and
russia and every other country
so it kind of leaves this thing hanging
there of well wait a second what's going
on here what is this
i want to read one more quote here for
the people at home that are saying all
right well this is just a few people
what are we really dealing with here i
also would encourage people go read the
article on dailywire.com it's worth
reading it's very interesting stuff
so this is lou elizondo he's the former
director of advanced aerospace
threat identification program so this is
that group harry reid created
they had hundreds of millions of dollars
in research over the years that they
were using
he said quote imagine a technology that
can do 600 to 700 g
forces that can fly at 13 000 miles an
hour that can evade radar and that can
fly through air and water and possibly
space
and oh by the way it has no obvious
signs of propulsion no wings no control
surfaces
and yet can still defy the natural
effects of earth's gravity that is
precisely what we are seeing
so this is a guy he's been in the
military for 30 years he's headed up
this top secret program that's now been
declassified
and he's coming out saying that's where
we are kind of putting a no on certain
terms so
there aren't really any comforting
answers on what this
is because if it is another country
we're screwed if it's aliens
theoretically we're screwed so the more
of the stories that were screwed like
wow thanks for that uplifting conclusion
because i i have always thought whenever
people talk about ufos i've always just
thought yeah it's
you know it's cold war spy planes or
okay after the cold war well whatever
it's the chinese or the russians or some
somebody's looking in on us and then
when people say well no it could it
could
maybe it's not i mean maybe there really
this technology is so advanced there's
just no way it's even one of our rivals
i i think i have the least popular
opinion on this at all
which is if there are intelligent
aliens and they are visiting earth in
tic tacs
and they're flying all around
i don't really care i i know that sounds
so insane
obviously it's a curiosity i read some
articles about it i'd watch some shows
but in terms of how i view myself
my place in the universe my religion my
philosophy my politics
i actually don't think it would change
very much well that makes sense because
the way that you view yourself in the
universe is at the center of the
universe
and so everything else is still just
revolving
for us average people with average
levels of intelligence and understanding
of the way that the cosmos functions
this is big for us michael so i know for
you this doesn't change much but
for us average folks this is a pretty
life-shattering thing for us to go
through
i can't believe what a softball i just
gave you i threw that it was so easy you
knocked it out of the park
cabot thank you very much you knocked
not only did you knock it out of the
park
you knocked out solar system baby that's
right
i am now defying the laws of physics
just like our martian friends
cabot thank you very much for this very
i'm not even i'm not even being
facetious here that was a
very insightful bizarre and interesting
report
[Music]
[Music]